Alabama Senate candidate Roy Moore is
losing more support over sexual
misconduct allegations three of the
state's largest newspapers are telling
voters to stand for decency and reject
him but Moore is still holding on to his
base of evangelical Christians Dean
Reynolds is in Birmingham Alabama and he
talked to one of Moore's accusers Dean
good morning good morning the newspaper
editorial calls the upcoming election a
turning point for women in a state that
is silenced them for too long it just
was a attack
really Gina Johnson was 28 when she says
Roy Moore sexually assaulted her back in
1991 she says she was with her mother
while visiting the then 44 year old
attorney to file custody paperwork we
got up to leave and when we did my
mother went fires didn't he grabbed me
from behind Johnson is one of nine women
one as young as 14 at the time who are
accusing Moore of sexual misbehavior
though Moore has consistently denied the
allegations some Republicans outside
Alabama are not convinced Maine senator
Susan Collins
I did not find his denials to be
convincing at all while president Trump
has remained silent about the
allegations against more this weekend
White House aide Mark short said this
about the president if he did not
believe that the women's accusations
were credible he would be down
campaigning for way more he has not done
that thou shalt not bear false witness
steadily supporting more AR Alabama's
evangelical voters many of whom believe
he'll support their positions on issues
including same-sex marriage and abortion
Carmon bro is one such defender they
want so much power in Washington and we
the people we want our power back we
want states rights and Roy Moore stands
up for states rights Tina Johnson
disagrees when you hear people attesting
to his character what would you tell
them quit being willingly ignorant the
special election will be held three
weeks from tomorrow and the deadline for
registration to vote in it is November
27
Gale all right Thank You Dean